hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Veronica success um we're both a little
sick right now so my voice is nasally
and her voice is so nice I'm not exactly
sick I just lost my voice yeah yeah I
lost my voice who's that good was it
that good
fantabulous
it was fantabulous when you lost your
voice huh what caused it to lose yours
I didn't say anything okay
well we're gonna watch today here's
basically what happened my brother
recently had a birthday and onion [ __ ]
that's the kind of brother I am and then
he got me a new microphone for my
birthday which was just a few days ago
so I thought what better way than to
give a gift then through watching one of
his new videos on the channel it is nice
it's really sweet see her brownie points
through her from brownie points with my
brother see cuz the best kind of gift is
promotion the gift that keeps on giving
they say help a brother out and that's
usually referring to someone who is not
your biological brother but this is my
biological brother is helping I'm
helping him out and plus it's free for
me so let's watch this video it's called
I carry 50 5s
it's your mother's fault Chloe sorry hey
check out my new film I traced 5s in
your face I hate making me Rachel of
course I mean I love you Chloe hey
pumpkin check this out
wait I love this thing that's it that's
the big security feature you paid all
that money for what they go no no no oh
did the big bad I trailer scare you know
were they scared Chloe can you just put
that thing away
I hate that thing
culture ballet
I do you you're making a face like I
look like an ass I feel like an [ __ ]
thing it's read it's just it's really
good
and I should be proud but I'm primarily
and now that I feel is I have three
beautiful successful gorgeous sisters
it's not spinach but it is green and
leafy no that was a cool video there
really was I mean I thought it was
edited really smart because like the
editing allowed all the trickery to
really take place there you know yeah
it's pretty funny concept - yeah the
acting was good yeah good I'm really
impressed by Chloe I got to meet all
three of them that's your responsibility
you know the way it was edit it was
really clever and like the car crash
sequence and everything you know I don't
know where my brother managed to get all
those guns from I was calm they were in
the car after the crash that's what me
the acting interesting was because it
wasn't like a realistic scenario so they
had a surreal presence about it all like
the acting and like all three of them
were on board for the same type of feel
this type of short cuz usually it's hard
to get three people who are on the same
page for something with this specific
kind of tone alright and these two
Chloe's always really smart
I like Chloe's adorable she's adorable
she never gets on my nerves uh-huh I
love her and she never gets on my nerves
with her hyperactive non-stop behavior
oh no he's being sarcastic I'm not being
sarcastic or her I thought you range
anywhere
randomly really quite nice where she
just stops talking to you for no
apparent reason I even liked her a lot
then how old is she she's old enough to
know that I'm being sincere right now
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can do that
and Veronica six toast has a channel you
could subscribe to her channel where she
does a lot of vlogging and music and
another [ __ ] it's that time of the video
Veronica's sixth time you know time of
the video that is yes I do
right now I'd know what time what time
it is it's show time
oh they were asking for the time for a
second just see you guys know it's 11:50
6 p.m. and we're all sick I'm not sick
no wait that's right that's right
yelling Matthew codes love all you
videos even love all you videos yeah
we're I'm a video we thinks we are just
videos that retreat it can i have a
shout out please PS sorry for asking so
much Matthew Coates
you haven't asked enough I take that
back one time asked is great enough as
it is it just confuses me if I can't
remember whether or not you know did I
get this person to shout cuz they might
have asked like 16 times now Matthew
Coates
you deserve a shout-out I've seen your
comments before I'm proud of you for
commenting subscribing channel comment
on her channel now yeah I'll respond
always do did you just get jealous man
are you jealous Hayden are you jealous
no II told this guy that you wouldn't
immediately respond to him I mean that's
I'm right in front of you you know yeah
whatever don't say you're sorry if
you're just gonna do it again so yeah
he's totally serious man is now seen
million won god I'm from Canary Islands
Spain and I love your videos keep up the
good work Ryan it would be a privilege
to receive a shout out there are canary
islands I'm very familiar with that is
where the birthplace of the writer of
King
Kong actually came from was the Canary
Islands and what else do you know about
the island
well our architectural II it was started
being developed in in 1458 alright and
it's full of a lot of you know you hear
Spain so you primarily think
spanish-speaking people in fact it's
actually Norwegian those are all facts
now see back me up on this would you now
see that's a very common name out there
it's like the joke goes in the Canary
Islands and now seed is like half of the
guys names or girls guys that really
help so how big Woody Allen he's so he
knows all those things I'm sorry I
better talk about now see the first time
you said it see your compliments meant
nothing to me at that time cuz my anger
was still up laughter you figured out
what I was actually saying did you then
feel good about it me now seed I do see
I did it
there's one subscriber that I've ever
had who's asked me for a shout-out
usually it's like cover request and I
just totally forgot where that guy what
where the comment was and I I just
thought I lost track of my one shoutout
I understand I understand the
difficulties of keeping track of your
shots you can continue now because I can
tell in your face yes Bruce Wayne can I
get a shout out if not I will find you
because I'm dead man oh you know what it
calls for right you know the shout out
calls for Batman voice overs on the
alter ego but he dear Joker impression
my father was it was a drinker and a
theme kind of sound like a nasally bully
I tried that's that's that
that's pretty good at they never learned
English only learned a communique like
in the end of the day my fighter Rachel
the next time weird you know what's up
with your obsession with friends
rachel is actually Bruce Wayne's lover
from the Dark Knight trilogy baby come
on buddy my girlfriend what are you
doing because I was thinking sir most
people yes it's fine it's staying in the
video